I'm gonna try to do everything by myself
today this should be fine as long as
everybody does so they're supposed to
Jim is to get Rosco so that's why I love
you kids go emergency PTA meeting today
at 5 o'clock we see you there
I'll totally get a sitter on a Tuesday
night actually what do I have in the
schedule today you're super late for
your marketing meeting soccer practice
I'm sorry okay I'm trying really hard
you the bake sale no BPA no MSG no BHA
no BHT no sesame no soy and of course no
nuts or eggs or milk or butter or salt
to sugar wheat no I'm so tired of trying
to be this perfect mom done who said
everything I've ever felt about you mom
but couldn't say there's [ __ ] rules
now don't punish your kid don't say no
to your camera
and all working hard trying to make our
kids lives amazing and magical their
lives already are amazing and magical
bad moms together cleaning let's uh keep
the novel Sweet Pea if you have to bring
down the perfect moms are those
store-bought donut holes
Oh destroy I say we go punch that chick
right in the tits
holy [ __ ] is that your mom bro so give
one long boo-boo this is my sexy bra
looks like you wrapped today's bandage
around touch it is it hot oh my god
it's like an eye mask but can you put it
in the fridge you got a very boys no the
right thing happening right now
catches 'never hard what's a never heart
he never gets fully hard so I just have
to cut up fool just penis up like a
balloon animal and fish it up inside me
okay that sounds horrible sometimes I
take the balls and shove them up there
too because at least you know they're
firm it's impossible to know whether or
not you're doing a good job my son still
watches Sesame Street and he doesn't get
it my son failed stay home my daughter
stole money from a homeless woman [ __ ] I
love them so much I would literally die
for them right now every time I think
about that big dumb [ __ ] going
up to college
I've heard something that's not possible
is it okay is it like a picture in your
head and then you think I've seen this
before
I just use the word before which means
I'm remembering something